ladies and gentlemen on
9 november 25 years ago courageous men
and women broke down the berlin wall
no wall the families ripped down a whole country
a whole continent arbitrarily because
two was great or
ricarda rieke controlled the hobby music and
liter the complete the league  the lotto
europa europa in the federal parliament when it was
about 23 million
germans can't even remember the fall of the wall because
they weren't born until after 85
but these young people could also have been
out of the fall of the wall just like
us politicians
we have to take care of that
see to it that young people learn from it we
are now coming to the amended
plan i now had the floor first to make
a statement to the
commission president a young peter young on
sunday the commission minister
i don't think it's a good thing to say that i
am here as commission chairman
and not  as former premier of
luxembourg luxembourg where matschie
ferie  n about mister ferrari spd end the
at
the bases specialist of show taxis in
alaska for tudor aspects eu criticism illegally pinned to
the wall communities
comes the belt resources international
turquoise in the exclusive psp go